as a public service once again we're  gonna look at a few Terms of Service  right now okay  for example the ride-sharing app uber  when you click agree on uber you agree  to listen patiently as your driver brags  about uber not finding out about his  latest DUI that's a true thing yeah  that's real HBO GO when you click agree  on HBO GO  you agree to lie and say yes when asked  if you understand Westworld yeah  eBay when you click agree on eBay you  agree that bidding on that vintage a  team lunch box won't magically transport  you back in time and fix your childhood  divorce is final Kevin the 7-eleven app  when you click agree on the 7-eleven app  we're sending help now were you in a car  accident in trying to dial nine-one-one  sorry it's just the first time anyone's  downloaded our app Google Translate when  you click agree on Google Translate you  agree to use it pretty much exclusively  to search for bathrooms and sex while  abroad  you  you